[Musique]
à part ce soir
qui d'entre vous si j'arrive au bout et
n'a pas entendu parler des progrès
fulgurants de l'intelligence
artificielle durant ils ont là la
semaine qui vient de se passer
qui n'a pas entendu parler
d'intelligence artificielle personnes
une personne c'est vrai que
l'intelligence artificielle est en train
de faire des progrès fulgurants
elle est en train de renverser l'empiré
humain vous le savez vous le lisez tous
les jours dans les journaux
pressé écrite la presse télévisée nous
serons bientôt entouré de voitures
autonomes 2020 2021
nous sommes entourés de robots qui vont
prendre notre travail dans un an ou deux
ça fait 35 ans que je suis dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
ça ne me rend pas plus jeunes et ce que
je vois la plupart du temps ce sont soit
des baudet qui utilise de vieilles
technologies pour essayer de résoudre
des problèmes qui devient effectivement
de plus en plus complexes ou alors ce
qui est de plus en plus probable
aujourd'hui des licornes
oui ça existe encore je les ai
photographiés entre martigny et monthey
un couple de licorne
on en rencontre tous les jours dans les
journaux dans les promesses des médias
les voitures autonomes les robots qui
vont prendre notre business
le serveur automatique la fin de l'
empire humains 50
ça fait plus de cinquante ans qu'on nous
dise ce cela que nous prédit la fin de
l'empiré humains au fond l'histoire de
l'intelligence artificielle a commencé
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
1944 le père de l'intelligence
artificielle
alan turing a été le premier au fond à
utiliser un ordinateur pour décoder le
le code allemand de sous marins
allemands
enigma il a été le premier à avoir
l'idée d'utiliser un ordinateur ou
plusieurs ordinateurs
pour remplacer ce que 250 scientifiques
n'auraient pas su faire en 150 ans pour
décrypter ce fameux code qui a permis de
gagner la deuxième guerre mondiale
le code énigmes à la série d'ordinateurs
qu'il utilisait à l'époque est largement
inférieures aux capacités de ce que l'on
a aujourd'hui dans le téléphone portable
ça fait cinquante ans que l'on a inventé
l'intelligence artificielle c'est le
seul transparent qui sera un tout petit
peu technique et encore il n'est pas
très technique mais alan turing à on en
a déjà parlé un petit peu avoir défini
ce test de turing qui explique
exactement comment définit à
l'intelligence artificielle bon faut en
gros on peut représenter l'intelligence
au sens large avec
deux grands cercles à gauche celui de
l'humain tout ce que l'humain peut faire
et que la machine difficile à faire et à
droite ce que la machine fait est que
l'humain a plus difficile à faire plus
l'intersection entre les deux cercles
seront grant sera grande plus nous nous
dirigerons vers une intelligence
artificielle finale qui sera capable de
prendre sur le monde la machine est très
bonne pour les statistiques le calcul je
vous échouez aux échecs jouer au gault
on pourrait le faire jouer à la belote
on pourrait le faire jouer au bridge et
finira par gagner tout ce qui est
systématique la machine extraordinaire
par contre l'humain a des capacités que
l'ordinateur n'a pas et n'aura sans
doute jamais l'empathie la communication
l'abstraction la compréhension la
communication sociale mais il faut pas
oublier que l'humain est très mauvais
dans certaines caractéristiques
par exemple la calcul des priorités un
humain est très mauvais un calcul des
corrélations
on a tous vécu le syndrome que j'appelle
le syndrome de la femme enceinte
une fois que votre épouse est enceinte
vous avez l'impression de rencontrer
beaucoup plus de femmes enceintes dans
les routes doigt les dangers dans la
ville si vous avez votre voisin qui
s'est fait cambrioler vous avez une
sensation très fort qui a une pénurie
très important de cambriolage pourquoi
parce que l'humain est très mauvais à
extraire l'information au niveau
statistique
il ya aussi le test de turing que l'on
devrait continuer à faire et dont on
devrait parler qui permet de décider
c'est une machine à des capacités
humaines ou pas on met une machine
derrière un rideau
enfin on met une machine est un homme et
de l'autre côté au magnum un homme qui
essaie de poser des questions à la
machine ou à l'homme et doit décider si
la machine est aussi bonne que l'homme
en une série de questions au jour
d'aujourd'hui
depuis la définition de l'intelligence
artificielle en 1945 il n'y a pas un
seul système intelligent sur la planète
qui a passé le premier test de turing
50 ans c'est ce qu'il faut en moyenne
pour prédire quelque chose dans le futur
aujourd'hui ça avance très très vite
si vous lisez dans le journal ceci
serait une start up dans deux ans les
voitures autonomes vont apparaître dans
deux ans on sera capable de faire ceci
dans trois ans c'est faux si ces cas
possible de le faire dans deux ans c'est
fait demain matin qui se rappelle de ce
film 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
je m'adresse aux personnes plus âgées
peut-être c'est le 50e anniversaire 50
ans cinquante un ans de du de ce film
2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
écrit par stanley kubrick pour la
première fois et peut-être la seule fois
en collaboration avec un des grands
scientifiques en intelligence
artificielle
marvin minsky qui est décédé il ya
quelques années
le jam haïti ils vont me ce scénario
ensemble 2001 odyssée de l'espace
il est intéressant de revoir ce film est
d'essayer d'en tirer les conclusions
on est en train d'écrire un livre où on
voit tout ce qui avait été prédit par
marvin minsky le pape de l'intelligence
artificielle en 1968 en externe les
kubrick qui n'est pas mauvais dans son
genre n'ont plus regardé le film je vous
invite à le revoir
aucune aucune sans exception des
prédictions qui avait été fait en 1968
n'a été réalisée les ordinateurs qui
reconnaissent la parole qu'ils
reconnaissent elles le visage qui rident
lit sur les lèvres salive pour ces
personnes qui ont vu le film qui qui est
doux et d'émotion
rappelez vous quand on débranche la
prise de l'ordinateur à quel point ils
souffrent avant de mourir et ses terres
et ses parcours les ordinateurs sont
toujours énormes dans une pièce avec des
bandes magnétiques
ils ont raté complètement le tablet
ils ont complètement raté les écrans à
couleurs ils utilisent toujours des gros
écran énorme en noir et blanc et c'est
donc tout ce qui a été prévu dit rien de
ce qui a été prise il est arrivé et tout
ce qui n'avait pas été prévenu est
arrivé 1990
george bush a déclaré j'étais encore
jeune à l'époque on était fier de porter
le pin's la décade indiqué of the brain
on était dans les conférences
d'intelligence artificielle bush a
déclaré que 1990 serait la décalade dit
kate décennie du cerveau et a investi 5
milliards de dol un japonais ont emboîté
le pas 5 autres milliards et les
européens sont venus comme d'habitude
beaucoup plus tard mais de nouveaux
à-coups de quelques milliards de dollars
ou d'euros
de dycker et of the brain 1990 2000 2010
vous pouvez chercher sur internet il est
gratuit maintenant ce livre 2010
un scientifique des mighty a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle dickey a tout dit
kate of the brain
je vous invite à le lire il tire les
conclusions de cet investissement
monumentale en intelligence artificielle
il ya deux grosses découvertes qui sont
expliquées dans le livre la première
c'est le décodage du génome humain qui à
mon avis n'a rien à voir directement et
le cerveau et la deuxième découverte
grâce aux confrères la compréhension du
cerveau humain
on a découvert une nouvelle pilule un
nouveau médicament antidépresseur
celui là je peux le comprendre c'est
bien 50 ans basé sur ma petite
expérience dans le domaine de 35 ans en
intelligence artificielle
je sais et beaucoup de scientifiques le
savent très bien que pour prédire les
journalistes me demandent souvent parce
que monsieur boulaire pouvez vous
prédire ce que va devenir notre
téléphone portable dans cinq ans
que va devenir ce si dans cinq ans dans
dix ans je leur réponds je crois que
quelqu'un a dit avant moi je ne sais pas
il est quasiment impossible de prédire
ce qui va y avoir dans cinq ans dans dix
ans car par expérience je sais
maintenant je le sais que pour prévoir
ce qui va se passer dans cinq ans il
faut pouvoir regarder
extrapolé sur les 50 dernières années
les développements vont tellement vite
qu'il faut regarder sur 50 ans pour
savoir ce qu'il va se passer sur les
cinq prochaines années c'est très
difficile d'extrapoler sur 50 ans il ya
cinquante ans il y aurait pas de
téléphone portable
donc quand on me dit où sera notre
téléphone portable dans cinq ans je dis
peut-être qu'on n'aura plus on va
peut-être téléphoner comme ça c'est pas
une blague
il faut être audacieux dans la vie
surtout quand on parle d'intelligence
artificielle et que l'on a l'ambition de
renverser l'empiré humain dernière chose
alan turing déjà en 1945 a dit quelque
chose de très important je pourrait
rebondir sur la vidéo que l'on a vu
avant la pause qui nous montrait que à
quel point on pouvait suivre les
personnes de reconnaître des chats et
des chiens et sait reconnaître n'est pas
comprendre reconnaître n'est pas
comprendre aujourd'hui en suisse si on
peut en effet on peut reconnaître bien
guère plus qu'une berceau des personnes
qui marchent un chat un chien on peut
reconnaître les lézards on peut
reconnaître les ballons les cailloux sur
le chemin les feuilles là ma dernière
conférence quelqu'un m'a demandé est ce
que vous pourriez si on a des voitures
autonomes est ce que vous pourriez
reconnaître un kangourou si jamais il y
avait un kangourou en sus oui on peut
reconnaître un kangourou
la réponse elle est toute simple on ne
fait pas de magie ici tout ça vient du
big data dont tout le monde parle si
vous me donner suffisamment d'exemples
de chats de chiens différentes races
différents exemples kangourou le wapiti
de koala et cetera je peux tout
reconnaître
je ne dis pas on va le faire dans deux
ans on peut le faire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on peut faire on peut
reconnaître des chats des cailloux des
feuilles des piétons ont des enfants des
chaises roulantes etc etc
des passages pour piétons on peut
reconnaître des voitures tout ce que
l'on veut mais reconnaître ne veut pas
dire qu'on a compris reconnaître au plus
reconnaître je peux reconnaître que je
peux quasiment compter toutes les
personnes qui a dans la salle ici je
peux reconnaître tout ce qui se passe
domicile si vous ne faites que
reconnaître vous n'irez pas très loin
une voiture autonome qui ne fait que
reconnaître elle sera pas être autonome
très longtemps je vous le garantis
mais même si vous reconnaissez tout ce
qu'il ya autour de la voiture jusqu'à la
feuille morte et un clou commentait ce
que la voiture à savoir qu'elle peut
rouler sur la feuille morte mais qu'elle
ferait mieux d'éviter le clou mais que
le caillou ça dépendra de la taille du
caillou comment est ce qu'on sait tout
ça si je suis à fribourg aujourd'hui mon
pied gauche étaient aussi à fribourg
c'est de la compréhension ça c'est du
sens commun
si je prends ceci que je le renverse
parfois je fais l'expérience dans ton
réel veut pas le faire ici je prends
ceci je renverse
c'est un petit remote controller le
renverse et toujours un remote control
je prends un stylo je renverse et
toujours un stylo je prends un verre
d'eau remplie d'eau je le renverse
c'est plus un verre d'eau c'est un verre
à eau
d'accord c'est de la compréhension ça va
bien au delà de la reconnaissance
comprendre et là on n'est nulle part
pendant qu'on injecte des milliards pour
reconnaître une personne et un chien et
la race des chiens et les kangourous
on ne comprend pas ce qu'il se passe et
l'intelligence artificielle aura besoin
de ça alors puisqu'on veut des
prédictions reconnaître t0 celui qui
vous dit ce sera fait dans deux ans il
faut pas le croire se sera pas fait dans
ce sens et fait aujourd'hui s'il vous
dit ce sera fait dans 50 ans iman il
espère que vous serez mort disent ils à
convaincre
vous voulez des prédictions comprendre
dans 50 ans y compris ok concors 50 ans
troisième point même si on arrive à
comprendre les scènes et là je vais
boucler mon exposé qu'est-ce qui ment
comme troisième point qui est
fondamental avant de les robots
envahissent la planète
les interactions sociales
l'humain est une bête sociale qui
communiquent en parlant de voiture on
pourrait pas je pourrais prendre
n'importe quand en particulier elle veut
en parler pendant deux heures mais
prenons les voitures puisque quelqu'un
aborder le problème avant - une voiture
autonome
non seulement il faut reconnaître tout
ce qui est autour de soi en espérant que
l'on sache encore le faire quand elle la
neige quand il pleut c'était donc amazon
ou google ils ont déjà tué deux
personnes dans le désert là où il y aura
quasiment aucune chance de rencontrer à
kyoto et pour le bleu le piéton qui
avaient ils ont créé ils ont tous réussi
à le tuer bon donc qu'au corps
reconnaître il ya quelques années dit
sion en suisse il ya un panneau pour
sensibiliser les autos les
automobilistes sur l'autoroute je sais
pas si vous en souvenez certains nous
disent il y avait juste deux vieux sur
le panneau je crois que c'était le tcs
ou la croix rouge
dieuze
deux yeux et une phrase suivez le regard
non mais c'est le panneau le plus génial
que j'ai jamais vu non mais c'est suivi
ça voulait dire quoi un regain on dit
beaucoup plus long qu'un clignoteurs etc
vous voyez un piéton qui traverse même
s'il n'est pas sur le passage pour
piétons vous vous regardez rapidement
dans les yeux le piéton c'est que vous
l'avez vu et vous vous l'avez vu c'est
juste la voiture autonome c'est le
reconnaît les pistes et les passages
pour piétons et les piétons et on lui a
dit il faut laisser passer le piéton sur
le passage pour piétons
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire la voiture
c'est le piéton n'est pas sur le passage
pour piétons interactions sociales
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est
très important je crois je vais en
rester là il me resterait encore deux
minutes mais je je pouvais
je veux continuer je vais continuer je
vais vous donner un autre exemple
mais avant ça je vais donner ma coquio
puis je rajouterais encore une phrase ou
deux quand j'entends parler de la fin
williams et koné parti la fin de la race
humaine là ils vont s'en va nous tuer
tous nos jobs
il ya eu une fois on entendu ça avant
bonjour la 2018 c'est en 1946 est une
invention phénoménal qu'à multiplier la
production par un facteur 10 productions
gaspillage aux siens il faut croire que
le capitalisme ça du mauvais aussi mais
il faut le savoir mais quelques caisses
qui a multiplié la production est là
donc la consommation par un facteur 10
tout le monde a crié à la fin de
l'humanité
et là ça allait tuer des jokes du
travail ces deux minutes 35
le seul service vous rappeler les seuls
services qui sont arrivés d'amérique
ça a tué tous les petits commerces etc
mais ça a créé beaucoup de marchés que
de business à côté énormément je dis pas
que c'était bon mais ça n'a pas tué tout
le monde tous les axes archamps j'ai un
petit peu modéliser le frère le contexte
commercial
d'accord le 2 min 04
je vais tirer ma conclusion s'il vous
plaît je suis un scientifique donc je
vais vous demander de ne pas être
technophobes ce serait une erreur d'être
technophobes n'ayez pas peur des
technologies n'ayez pas peur de ce qu'on
vous dit sans doute vous passez dans les
journaux c'est génial ce qui se passe
c'est excitant et on va aller de plus en
plus loin et de plus en plus vite
mais par contre ne soyez pas
technophiles et n'achetez pas tout ce
que vous lisez dans les journaux on est
loin de rencontrer des robots qui vont
courir après vous qu'ils vont jouer au
football
contre une équipe d'humains très loin je
vous le garantis reposez vous regardez
le travail des scientifiques
tout va bien r d pour l'avs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]